[Music]
[Applause]
no
i am now and i apologize item two
conflicts of interest any conflicts of
interest for
uh minuting no
thank you we move on to confirmation of
minutes
of the audit and risk committee of the
15th of september
can i have a move it council award
seconded by the mayor that we confirm
the circulated minutes of the september
15th
meeting is a true and accurate redhood
any
items for correction no i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
against
declare it carried thank you uh
3.2 matters arising from those minutes
any matters arising
no all right um move on to item
four um presentations and deputations
now even though
miles you're sitting there you're for
the report when we get onto reports
you're not
proposing as a deputation are you no
no no that's all right thank you
so we now do move on to reports
and the first up is the draft report
and unaudited accounts for enterprise
north canterbury for the year
ending june the 30th and also the um
promotion uh district uh business plan
report also to june the 20th so i
i invite simon's down here as presenting
that is he not um
here who's no okay
all right over to enterprise north
canterbury to um to take us through
those two items thank you
you sandra um i would just like to start
with introducing
um miles business support manager at
enterprise north canterbury who's going
to introduce jamie
um the reason we've brought jamie here
today is just to
rather than us tell us about the good
things that we've been doing um
particularly post covert but in the last
12 months
and prior um rather than us telling us
about ourselves we thought we'd bring in
a business like we did one other time
just to so about his experience with
enterprise north canterbury
and the support he's received so over
two miles
hi everyone i'd just like to introduce
jamie from total span north canterbury
and wood end
we started working with jamie and alan
about six years ago when they first took
over the business
so i'll pass over to you jamie
yeah good morning all hey i'd just like
to say a couple of words
on behalf of wife allen who couldn't be
here today and uh total span north
canterbury
um initially we were
members of the chamber of commerce um
you know we purchased our business in
and you know we become a member of
chamber chamber of commerce just to sort
of you know
um get on board and get some systems
built up in our business that
that were non-existent um we felt there
we were
you know a small fish in a big pond um
you know we come across enterprise north
canterbury um i'm pretty sure it was via
facebook or
or advertised through the news so we
kind of contacted enterprise north
canterbury
and you know the initial response was
really
you know welcoming him and um yeah we
built an instant rapport
which which was fantastic so so what
enterprise north canterbury and and
particularly miles who were we were yeah
he was our um
you know direct contact um he provided
for us was a
um you know a um
a business evaluation and and set up a
business plan for us
that included um you know specific
systems uh you know budgeting systems
marketing plans
um all those sort of courses were were
available which we which we took place
um right through to you know systems
around
staff culture you know
conflict management and also time
management which were very vital to
getting our business up and running
because like i say we just you know it
was quite a daunting process for us at
the start we we
we didn't really have anyone to lean on
and um you know
it's sort of they picked us up out of
the gutter so to speak and
and got us where we needed to be so
know a lot along the way um you know
miles has been
fantastic with the communication um you
know he's always there at the end of the
phone
end of an email if we need to know
anything or or have any questions
or what courses are available coming up
that can help us in specific
areas you know we
we're obviously the the winners of the
the previous
um north canterbury business awards
which was a great achievement for us
and the team back at total spa north
canterbury
during that process the application was
you know extremely complex and
you know we needed some support around
that also
you know right through to you know once
we've completed the application
we'd send it through to moles and he was
he'd kindly check it off and
give us any pointers on where we needed
to be and
you know and and make those tweaks along
the way so
um yeah he's yeah as far as we're
concerned yeah it was it was
without that support um you know i don't
believe would be
would ever reach those goals that we had
set in place um
yeah so that so the process throughout
the business awards
process helped helped us learn and
understand our business
and set targets and goals and action
plans for the future
and like i say the support was all was
always there
throughout covert um obviously that's
that's been a big player and
in most people's businesses the support
was there also
we were able to gain funding for
business mentors
hugely discounted um funding for that
which we've taken on board taking the
opportunity
and it's great to have the opportunities
here that you can grab um
right at your fingertips and be being
local
as well um that's that's been been a
great help for us so you know they're
only sort of
five minutes down the road from where we
are we jump in the car we go down there
that's where the courses are generally
held
um that we go on so everything's local
and and really handy
for us so yeah during covert was
you know that i mean that was another
part
you know of our business that we we
didn't really know whether it was going
to fail or
you know what was going to happen and um
nobody knew um and fortunately it's you
know
it's taken a turn and it's extremely
busy at the moment
and we're capitalizing on that as a
complete opposite to how we thought it
was going to
unfold but yeah the support was
definitely there to get us through
um through that part um
so yeah so yeah i mean i'll take my head
off these guys uh you know hopefully
they're out there supporting other small
business as well which i'm sure they are
and and other businesses are coming to
them for that support because it's you
know
um yeah it's been really helpful for us
going forward um yeah so that's about
what i've got to say really yeah thank
you very much and i just wondered
whether any of the
the councillors here want to ask jamie
any questions
uh council redmond
thank you it's good to hear your story
um what
are you still having ongoing involvement
with enc
absolutely what assistance are they
currently providing
yeah so so like i say we're still we're
still working through the um
the other funding for for business
mentoring um which
we're working with currently and um
yeah we have we haven't got any future
stuff coming up but yeah we're just
concentrating on
you know just the business mentoring at
this stage um
because we're sort of you know we've
built the business up now we're
you know that they gave us a leg up you
know at the start
and um although you've got to keep
maintaining
your business along the way which we're
doing by engaging
mentors and things like that um yeah
whenever we need the support we'll
we'll reach out so at the stage we are
working with them
and um you know through the through the
business mental
side of things thank you mr mayor
um like council redmond thank you for
um your affections really i think it's
been really helpful to hear
um i hear from um enc
around the community as well to support
the enc offer to our businesses
just interested while you're here you're
talking about how you've recovered post
covert which is really
excellent what's your ford program
looking like and
how optimistic are you feeling about our
local economy and what's happening here
is your market local or is it a lot
broader
than that with your total spam business
here yeah sure so
so so there's 28 um uh
total spam franchises in new zealand and
we're all sectioned off into
you know certain regions obviously and
so so we're north of the wymac river
through to south of the clarence river
in kaikoura so that's our region
it's quite quite a fast area we go right
up to maria springs if you want to you
know
head up that way um so we um
yeah it's the industry's the building
industry
um is booming at the moment and
um you know we we've taken on extra
resource to get through the work
there's a huge amount of building going
on we do a lot in ravenswood
the commercial sector there so
so we've got you know storage units
coming up for the air and you know
there's just a lot of
commercial growth as well as as
residential stuff so
that's right across the board we we do
housing commercial
you know your residential sheds and
garages and things like that so
um you know for instance to put in
perspective
from november to november um as
a rolling year we sold 156
buildings when over a 12-month period
we'd do
uh sort of 90 to 100. so
yeah that's that's huge for us and like
i say just
just to get that resource in place so we
can you know
um you know get those projects completed
is probably the
the number one key but the sales just
keep coming in the door for us and
you know and that's that's not by chance
it just doesn't happen
you know boy yes it's reputation it's
you know
it's it's getting the help putting
systems in place
it's all that sort of thing and you
can't just sit on your hands and think
always heaps of work out that's going to
come to us it doesn't happen like that
so so so we we don't we we do go out
there and we and we advertise and we
you know like i said with all the
systems set up um bring in the extra
resource
when we need it and um yeah there's huge
growth growth in north canterbury um
in comparison um to the rest of
canterbury
um north canterbury's definitely um you
know
as far as total span is concerned as
leaps and bounds
ahead of the um the canterbury branch
and in town
um however you know a lot of the north
island branches are definitely booming
through your
mental tour and auckland places like
that as well so
continue to continue growth yes um i do
believe that will be the case
for how long i don't know
just that step that you said before or
just remind me of those figures before
how many you build
in a normal year and where you're
currently sitting at the moment yeah so
so in regards to sales
um sales units so they could be anything
from a car port to a to a house
so we'd do between 90 and 100
units um per year this was this is
pre-pre-covered sort of in between
earthquake times and free covert um
and and we're up to 156 buildings for
for a rolling year since november last
year so
it's it's i mean you could almost say
it's gone up another
you know 50 almost really yeah which is
you jay
council award
thank you um it's great to hear a good
story after the covert
um i just want to ask of two or three
things um
were you still operating encoded there's
one question
the next question were you able to
access funding from the government
because of perhaps lack of turnover
and the third thing is your resources
when you say resources
how many full-time staff do you have and
how many
what other resources do you put on when
you need it are they temporary
sure or is that looking to be more
full-time so i'm really interested in
hearing how many people you're actually
employing at the moment
sure and um really interested that
you're very reliant of course on the
farming community which is important to
the infrastructure district so so don't
answer your first question there um
we we we were able to um
um still operate from
you know our staff working from home um
obviously we have we have staff and and
contractors
so we were still making sales by by
working from home
um we we receive our um
you know inquiry via the internet and
phone
and and a lot of the time we're going to
split a display and what in there and
they just drop into the into the office
and have a look around our display
however predominantly obviously over
covered
lockdown a lot of that inquiry come
through the internet
so our sales staff were obviously able
to work from home
connect up to the work server still be
able to provide quotes
all that sort of thing talk to people on
the phone so so all that was still
operational
however contractors
uh they said at home for a month and a
half and did nothing so
the beauty of it was as well the council
was still operating
which meant that you know we had close
to about
probably 20 building consents in council
and you know they they were very
efficient too i must say
and and actually pushing those consents
out and approving them for us
however when we got back into into the
the build phase
we had 30 buildings here ready to go
right now
you know and our customers you know they
were they were quite relaxed about it
they understood that we've been locked
down for a month and a half and couldn't
build anything all our projects just
basically went on hold
so so we went close to about 40
buildings there
and and progress um that we had to get
off the ground and get moving
asap so so yeah we were still able to
make sales and yeah like so we just
couldn't we couldn't touch them
they just sat until we you know until we
had the lockdown lifted
so so during that um yeah we we lost a
bit of turnover
um you know we we also um
we we applied for the government funding
um
and yes there's a loss in revenue there
because we're turning over the jobs and
so on and so forth and
and and that was really easy to obtain
um
you know we applied for the money was in
the bank basically the next day and
and that was that was able to help us
get through and
and into the next stage so although we
had a lot of customers deposits in our
bank account because they were still
paying their bills everybody was still
paying their money it was it was quite
unbelievable
um you know you know human nature would
be oh
sure we're going to go into a recession
we'll hold on to our money that wasn't
the case
people were paying their bills flat out
and um
yes just what about supply you know
suddenly suddenly got 40 to build so
you're still able to get um
supply of the equipment to to do erect
the building
yeah that didn't seem to be an issue
it definitely put strain on our factory
you know because i wasn't the only ones
that had the only franchise that had 40
buildings in there there's probably
like i say 28 other franchises that had
the same amount yeah quantity of builds
in there but
for some reason we managed to keep up
with the supply
um and it was it was a systematic
approach to it you know
you sit down and think about it
strategically and how it was all gonna
you know from getting your concrete
floors down earthworks operators so
it was just it was just a matter of
engaging more resource to do that
which we had yeah at our fingertips
because
you know people or contractors in
general generally like to
to work for a company like us um
you know and you know a reputable brand
and you know they've
they get paid and they move on to the
next one
so it's a pretty good system that we've
got in place in regards to that
um so your gathering resource wasn't too
much of an issue really
well thank you council about it
still on the employment line so how many
full-time staff
have you got here yeah and are you
looking to expand it at all in the next
12 months
yes so so what we've got i'm sorry that
was part of your question
that's right uh so so what we've got in
our office here at woody end is um
we run with two sales staff
um project manager uh
which is uh myself because you know
during cover i thought we were going to
go into a recession but we weren't so i
had to make that call to
um you know to let a staff member go
however you know on the flip side it's
um you know
i really need somebody to fill that role
now but i was sort of taking it upon
myself and
and so it's myself as a manager and i do
the project management which which that
role is usually filled by another
employee uh office edmond and my wife
ellen who generally looks after miles
and
and all the marketing side of things and
and and whatnot
uh working with heather and that as well
so um yeah so that's generally how it
works and then contract teams two
full-time build crews
concreters all that sort of thing we've
actually got three full-time build crews
at the moment so
so if you needed more staff where would
you find them from normal
uh more staff um generally we would find
them
genuinely would find them word of mouth
really um
you know for us i think that's that's
the best way is is actually
obtaining the word of mouth checking out
their work um you know when it comes to
contractors staff were okay
with the office staff were probably at
where we need to be
um however yeah we use a
um we use hr for you know for employing
office staff and
and things like that we get involved as
well but generally hr would take care of
the applications and so on and so forth
through through hr yeah yeah um
yeah but contractors yeah generally they
would they would sort of you know
be word of mouth and and and whatnot so
thank you councillor duty
thank you um one of those questions uh
you've actually answered was the hr
so you are the outsource for hr to do
your job is that right
your projects yes yes we outsource hr
yeah that's it
the other question is in the being the
area that you
are involved with a lot of rural um do
the rural counterparts give you a good
good business um i mean to
to be honest um
we we don't actually do a lot for for
the rural community
all right yeah it's it sounds bizarre
yes we are into sheds yes we
we do do those buildings um however
predominantly
our niche market is the lifestylers
so we love the likes of milfield estate
we love you know
the the 10 acre blocks um 2 000 square
meter blocks uh
you know they're perfect for big sheds
yeah um the rural community but yes we
do do a few
you know um generally the you know if
they build a farm house we'll put the
shed next to it
um but predominantly they'll they'll use
like a pole
type setup that's wrapped there on over
the sides nothing flash
that'll do however we're sort of
i mean don't want to blow our own
trumpet or upmarket and and we're
a little bit more expensive than your
standard pole shed
so that works great for the rural
community however yeah we sort of
concentrate more on the
you know the and niche market our
lifestyles and the biggest shares paid
caravan boats and things like that
and leave the flat roof farm buildings
to the likes of um
gold pineal or something like that
that's a lot more cost effective while
building
and likewise when farmers move off farms
yep you can always tell with where
they've bought because there's always a
shed go up
oh yes you're exactly right there and
and and and that's that's where we pick
up the rural community i suppose
yeah the the retirees yeah they come
straight to us and say look
you know a little scared what can you do
big shed big
and you're right you're exactly right
what you're saying thank you
thank you thank you very much um uh
any more questions counselors no well
perhaps um
heather you can take us through the
substance of uh
okay um i'd just like to thank jamie and
release them now
from the questions to build
he's got a busy day ahead of them thank
you very much jamie hey thank you very
much for having me too it's been a
pleasure
yeah thank you welcome cheers just the
first few slides
yes yes thank you right
um if we could turn what what i'd like
to do is also
introduce um my chair holly yes we've
met holly and claire but if you want to
move over
you can feel free i'm gonna stay here
because i've got a presentation so you
too
yeah it's right sit here you both can
sit there
and you sit there miles yeah
so um what i'd like to do is just take
you through and also clear
uh giffit is one of our valued board
members so
welcome claire and holly yeah thank you
um i'd just like to take you through
just a small presentation on our
projects for the year that has been in
some of the opportunities ahead
and i just asked miles to stay because
he can talk a little bit around the
business support that we've provided as
an organisation
in the last 12 months and post covert
and i think
it's been outstanding and i'm really
proud of the team that
miles leads guy and tanya i'm also
most proud of the way that enc as an
organisation
adapted immediately to the response of
covert
um and we went into action as we did
post earthquakes
and i think that local knowledge of
local businesses
has actually always stood in good stead
um that we do know the businesses by
name a lot of them
and we were in contact with
them by email and newsletters there were
things changing every day with the
government announcements and so we
wanted to keep them updated
and also make sure that they didn't miss
out on anything that was available to
them
so i just wanted miles to cover off on
the business support
numbers that have been astronomical for
us as a small organisation
particularly like jamie said
he's doubled 50 or more of his turnover
normally in a year we deliver 80 000
to businesses in the last nine months
alone
we've delivered over 665 000
directly to businesses so miles if you'd
like to take
um through just the next couple of
slides yeah um
the covered response was very
interesting because of course we were
all working from home
so first thing of course was to set up
systems because there were no systems
for this
um and we found that our system worked
well especially compared to other areas
um just keeping it simple i always try
and strip things back
but in terms of the number of businesses
we helped almost 900 businesses since
march 25th to date
um and a good number of those
were full interviews so not just um
a quick email or a phone call but
actually really delving into what they
needed at that time
and generally it was one issue so
but yeah we we issued vouchers for 432
businesses for covert response and there
was also businesses with the tourism
response as well
and that was a horrible process because
the systems that were set up at the
government in
just weren't made to handle it so there
was a lot of back and forth
over that we also noticed that
a lot of businesses were wanting to
apply for the ird loans but in order to
access those
they needed to have full cash flows and
of course to get full cash flows cost
money so they were trying to
they were having to spend money to
borrow money um so
the board and heather decided that it
would be wise if enc actually funded
that directly from our own
own reserves we had at that time um so
we funded
uh 61 grants for businesses that wanted
to take on the ird loans but
couldn't actually afford at the time to
get the information they need to get
those loans
so yeah massive and what we've seen
since
covert is quite a massive
increase in the number of people looking
at starting up businesses
so some of the stuff we'd already put in
place served us well so we'd already set
up a free online course people could
attend
a whole heap of resources um but of
course there's the
one-on-one interviews as well so we've
helped with that
we've also set up which has just started
uh this
this month a business startup course for
people who wanted to go
into depth and do the full market
validation etc etc
which is there um do you want to talk
about the
team up with michelle so in the past
enc's partnered with
msd here in canterbury and
we've been able to we had uh pete bank
for two years following the kyboy
earthquake
based in kaiapoi we had michelle wilson
following the earthquake
in hiranoi the wire but they call it the
kaikoura earthquake
and that was really useful because it
applies the
msd thinking and and funding
to our businesses and that's not that's
not our space but we bring somebody in
to
bring that knowledge into our
organization so we approached msd again
and michelle becks who's a senior work
broker here in rangiora
with siconda 2m encn has been based
there since
april um in post covert and that's been
instrumental in widening her
outreach to businesses so she's got a
lot more
a lot to know a lot more businesses as a
result of our
database and our introductions but we've
also
gleaned a lot of michelle and she's put
a lot of
work uh sorry um subsidies flexi wage
subsidies
apprenticeship boosts mahayan
mahimani so there's been a lot of
opportunity to cross-pollinate and
benefit businesses and one particular
one was
the unemployment to self-employment and
that's what
miles had been hearing so we said look
let's put an application to msd
to run a like almost a be your own boss
workshop that they used to run
many years ago and we were able to
secure
craig rust to do that and we've got
funding to run
two workshops 15 people per workshop
five
five courses five hours one-on-one
coaching that will
really give the business potential
business owner a hand up to really
get the grasp of what the business is
market validate pricing and costing and
then go forth
so msd have been um very
supportive in supporting enc we're the
only organization in new zealand that's
received this funding
and i guess it's because we're at that
coalface and we're in that partnership
so that was one of our new projects so
we've actually been not just responding
to
existing businesses but we've actually
been working with new business
startups and another new project that
started during covert
alyssa took on the role of a business
development manager
for food and beverage north canterbury
and we've
gone through a process of branding and
naming it and it's called made
and it's a local provenance by local
program
that supports local food and
beverage producers across the both
districts but
certainly getting a lot of uptake um
around that
and just as a one-off because we're
waiting for a website to go live for it
um we're working with new world robin at
new world and
principal street bakery and taking
orders for christmas hampers
85 and you get um all local product
that you can give as a gift as a
corporate to staff or
to your employees which and clients so
we think it's a small initiative right
now but it's a it's a two-year project
and it's fully funded by mb which is
ministry of
uh business innovation and
employment um so the district promotion
con so that's our economic development
side of things and then our district
promotion contract
is one that has four streams of funding
around the four hundred thousand dollars
and one of the funds funding
streams is business promotion or a
business investment
and that's miles's role that this
council funds
um it's also the visitor attraction role
which is around where once is never
enough for the wa
district and we in the last 12 months
period
have been developing a discover section
that's about
discovering our region our district
capturing new video and imagery for our
new website that's going to go live
early next year
um distributing the official visitor
guide that we have produced and do
produce on
every second year basis along with the
street maps for the towns
we also maintain a website and have a
very strong facebook presence
um we also registered to attend trends
but that didn't happen this year it was
cancelled
because of covert and
we put a hold on all outward marketing
because
uh it wasn't uh it was because of covert
in february we knew then
that the marketing had to go on hold so
that funding's been brought forward to
this financial year
and we're still concentrating on the
cycle trail development
of the eastern side of the district we
see a very
obvious loop we don't call it the
eastern
cycle loop but we're trying to get some
connections between
the already very strong and fantastic
infrastructure that the council and
he can do but then we can't call it a
loop because it's not joined up so they
are trails
and we've established a um
on online and also flyers because we get
a lot of cyclists coming in where do we
go
how long is it going to take us so we've
got to i'll hand that out
um a very comprehensive uh list of those
cycle trails but
we'd love to get in behind this and
develop it as a product
so that our towns benefit kaya poi
wood end and pegasus rang europe because
it goes through all our towns
people will be stopping for recreation
and and refreshments and we think
there's a huge opportunity with the
bridge
opening um in december and i think i've
mentioned it already i would love to see
a cycle counter go on that cycle lane
as soon as it opens so we've got some
really clear data
from start into one year into it how
many cyclists
are coming over on you know the weekends
and during the week
don't worry about that neil's resonance
yeah
no i can't i don't know how to do that
sorry
wouldn't you just do it wouldn't you do
a little and pegasus around
the lake too because obviously
absolutely listen
it's in this yes and that's why we've
developed this
yeah and i'll pass it around it's very
comprehensive
and um and yeah there's certainly going
to be a lot we just put that up
yes it is absolutely um
we operate the eyesight so that's the
other hundred roughly ninety thousand
dollars that's of the four hundred
thousand that we
operate the eyesight and we got impacted
this year because of covert
we were closed for eight weeks um we
were going strong
and then it just dropped off so um
gwen was working with the business
support team we were reaching out to
operators um we also she took some time
off
it was pretty um comprehensive downturn
of
income and visitor numbers and
interestingly during covert
christchurch ice sites both of them the
airport and the city closed
and they've been put into permanent
hibernation
because cr eyesight new zealand are
actually
reinventing themselves so they go into
the government with the
opportunity to buy 15 strategic
tier 1 eyesight so no doubt that one of
those will be christchurch and
christchurch know this
and they will government will own the
ice sites going forward of those 15
larger
15 to 20 larger and will leave the
smaller eyesights to be managed and
owned by local government
as it has been for this this small
eyesight
um it is a high profile site and we are
getting a lot of calls from christchurch
so they don't have now an eyesight so um
and on their answer phone they're saying
call chiropoint eyesight
on christchurch nz website it says call
kyopoi eyesight
so i've actually applied for more
funding through the community resilience
funding
covert 19 to get some support for gwen
because she's the only person in the
eyesight
and it's now becoming too much for one
person
so i'm not coming back to council for
that but i'm adequately assured i'll get
some funding
um for the next 20 weeks to just help
through this busy time
again we're going to get a lot more
people coming because the brew pub the
river queens the cycling
um and we need to be open six days a
week over the summer
they're not going to reopen
i already approached them
um event promotion is the other one
hundred thousand
roughly forty thousand thirty to forty
five thousand is event funding
itself so we administer that and it goes
out to the event organizers so
of that hundred thousand we don't keep
that uh for
forty five thousand and the rest is
actually around the promotion and
lucy doing her push out of event
calendar producing it as you would see
every month
we produce an events calendar this is
november's it gets distributed
electronically and physically
but more importantly it's been picked up
by
um i think last year it was 24 online
but it's actually grown to a lot more
than that
facebook community facebooks and they're
sharing it with their communities of
users
and reaching over 51 000 people every
month
locally and further afield so we're
really gaining a lot of traction around
our event promotion
we've also just been advised through mb
they're going to
be positing 150 000 into our bank
account over the next
uh two to four years so um it's a gift
and we want to consult with local event
organizers
and look at a strategy how we would
spend that money
um it's not for me to determine but it's
a really good opportunity to build on
the events that are already here
and get in behind some really some new
signature events i think
and particularly with the indoor stadium
um there's going to be a lot more
opportunities for indoor events
potentially
and miles who you've been working with
um it got a bit quiet over covered
strangely enough but um
it seems to be heating up quite a lot
now one of the projects i did look at
over covered when we thought there was
going to be a lot more unemployment than
there was
was starting to look at projects that
are more about
jobs rather than enhancing places and
one of the ones that's fallen out of
this
is a taiwanese pet food factory who
would be employing 100 staff
who are now looking at establishing
kaiapoi
they're looking at two sites one in kai
for one in christchurch so we've got a
friendly battle going on
and we'll just have to see how that goes
it's not quite at the stage yet where it
needs to go to council but i've had a
good talk with simon about what they
would need to put in place to make it
work
if they do get to that stage so we just
wait and see on that one
there's a few few that have sort of
pivoted so one of the construction
companies is now looking at setting up a
houseboat company
in waimakariri um which will be quite
interesting
um and
the water park i hope you know about
that one
we're sort of we're sort of not needed
in that picture now that's
we've taken that as far as we can help
them now it's with the council who are
treating them very well
um and if it gets to the start the next
stage then we'll probably come back into
the picture again
um i've been working on various hemp
projects
which are mainly happening in the
hiranui but will have an impact in the
waimakariri as well
uh oh the oxford observatory
um you've probably heard about that one
as well i've been working with
james who is the astronomer trying to
set up the oxford observatory as
a tourism project that's taken a wee bit
of a back seat at the moment because of
course it would rely on international
tourism
so we're doing a bit more on the
planning up front
and we'll see how that goes there's a
lot to do with ministry of education and
the school and getting the right people
involved and setting up the right
structures
but if we can do that it'll be a lovely
little tourism attraction for
oxford and give a real sense of pride to
to the town
and i mean one of the things about
oxford is you want to bring more people
in but you don't want to bring too many
more people in
because you don't want to re ruin the
atmosphere that's already there
so there's some other projects working
on i'm working on 24 projects at the
moment those are the more interesting
ones
thank you okay just a quick summary
um this has been here like no other even
you know this has been a health crisis
that's become
an economic crisis more than a health
crisis um
and it is a very uncertain year next
year we've seen the numbers that simon
markham and
his team have put up that is national
predictions that we may take a dip next
year
but we will still be in this space i
would just like to personally thank the
enc
board who are all volunteers
volunteering their time
and their energy and a strong governance
to
me and my team i'd like to also thank
the foundation support we receive from
this council particularly as we've
secured an additional
627 thousand dollars
of external funding as a result of the
foundation funding we receive for you
and that's just been in the last year
we've got a big delivery program ahead
of us
um we're excited by it we're excited by
the new visitor strategy
a new event strategy
we want to work closely with waimakari
district council to establish that
cycle trail development
and i'm happy to take any questions uh
miles and i and we can talk about the
financials
but i'd also like holly to say a few
words if that's okay
yes certainly holly over to you thank
you
look i just think um it's amazing if we
reflect on
our adaptability as human beings and one
of the
real wow factors for me this year has
been
watching the team at enterprise north
canterbury
come together very cohesively
and very well to respond quickly
to the needs of our local communities
and while that might be
in business i think it also comes down
to the fact that
the businesses i brush holders with have
said a timely conversation
from those that understand my business
and my environment has meant more to me
than
the conversation i've had with my lawyer
or my accountant or my bank
and so when i think about enterprise
north canterbury and the reason that
i enjoy so much working with the board
and with the staff
is that they do provide a unique service
to our community and it's not able to be
mimicked very easily by any other entity
and i think that's been shown in the way
in which businesses
are still here ready to respond to what
is quite an unknown
future in the way that they can
look at their business understand it
better as a result of conversations with
the likes of miles
and with the resources they've had and
they've taken the time
and lockdown to prepare themselves for
change
and one of the constants for all of us
will be the change that we need to deal
with
over the coming year but i think it's
also about recognising the opportunities
as they arise and being able to act
swiftly
so i'd just like to credit heather and
miles and the rest of the team
for being able to respond so quickly and
what we're quite trying
circumstances working in you know
bedrooms in their home that were less
than ideal with a lot of distractions
um and i know that you know for us as a
board the challenges of communicating
and coming together
while responding in our own businesses
were immense
but i'm very proud of what they've done
so i too would like to thank the council
for their
partnership with us and i'm just really
looking forward to
us rising to the challenges of this
coming year
thank you now i've got a list of
councillors who want to ask questions
starting with
councillor barnett
no you're you're done in dust today
right council award
just a quick question and i'm sure it's
a yes um but
with the ravenswood um township and that
road from wooden road connecting through
to the roundabout
to pegasus that means then that the
cycleway can
proceed and be complete through the
pegasus
is that correct that's my understanding
with speaking with jenny yes
so that'll be and that'll be on your map
it will be yes
the map we can't as i said right now we
can't develop a loop
until we've got those connections
all right council williams thank you
honey miles just a question on cairport
you mentioned a pet food business and
boat house building is there enough
land available for and carpool for
these type of business to put buildings
on and do it or
absolutely so and are there
the other thing are there any existing
big buildings that are capable of doing
this at the moment
no no so that's all not not available
buildings
and whereabouts is the land
i would probably like not like to say
without the permission of the owner
it sounds right though is it no
we'll work on that that's what that was
my main question what was the
is there
that's one of the reasons i've had
discussion with council to look at what
the process would be because what we've
done
is we've found the right piece of land
with the wrong zoning
but it's situated in a place that isn't
too difficult to change necessarily
yeah colton thank you um
the mayor thank you thank you heather
and team for the presentation
um heather um around um
tourism strategy marketing last couple
of days there's been a few emails
circulating i'm not sure if you're aware
of those
um so there's some interest from some
community board member from various
community boards
and i like rinks here in the audience
today
just wonder if you've got any um
thoughts about
how those ideas could be potentially
considered
and in advance if you're given any ideas
to
any thought to that
um i honestly am open to any ideas
a new strategy means new direction and
i read in the emails that it didn't seem
different um it was a refresh it wasn't
her
we didn't have i think the change
wasn't imminent but we think there's a
lot of change
coming and so um and i don't know that
that was actually
reflected in um the strategy well but i
would be open to
community board members maybe a
delegation from each community board
to meet with potentially
yourself the mayor and myself and
and come together and discuss and yes
the portfolio holder
for district promotion um i think in in
a board member i think
governance is important um from
uh maybe clear i would be keen because
she's got an invested interest in
the visitor strategy herself um i think
that would be maybe a way
forward
thank you heather excellent um a
councillor duty
thank you very much for your good report
it's excellent um
the the question i'd like to ask please
is um have you considered and amongst
your lot because we've got three really
good golf courses
have you not thought about perhaps doing
a a promotion
because like like all small
organizations that top the money's tight
but they they just i think they all the
whole three probably need a good
shot of steam to help them through so
that's just something to think about
plus the the environment and the the
beauty
of the three of them is as well
worthwhile promoting and it's not just
waimakariri but also
hirano as well they've got fabulous
scenic ones so it's just something to
think about from that point of view
the other um thing is street maps
um now can can they get reprinted or
what's the story with that uh we've
still got considerable supplies
so when they run out we reprint them oh
that's good yes and they're funded by
our sponsors which is devlin and um
and hackles good thank you um the other
thing
is um for the website i mean the
the events promotion with your your um
monthly newsletter
those people that are ringing out from
christchurch can you are you shooting it
out to them as well
yes we do targeted facebook posting to
north of christchurch
excellent yeah you can actually pick
areas demographics ages
kirsten knows all about that so that's
good yeah so the other thing
um uh miles um opec have just funded a
thousand dollars towards
um the observatory to help them to set
up this 16-inch
telescope outside yeah they're wanting
000 to get a new one for inside so
um that's something that probably needs
they may need a little bit of a helping
hand of
how to go about hmm
excellent all right council about it
did come across two more questions while
i was thinking um
when i looked at one part you talked
about rural businesses but
you didn't mention oxford or castle
i'm trying to find the section um what
is being done to help the
the rural businesses in waimakariri
um if we were talking maybe about the
rural businesses in
hironui i think it was around the hemp
producers
and it would be around the wine growers
they're probably specifically the two
we actually don't work with directly
with sheep and beef farmers
because there's rural townships oh okay
sorry
okay right yes okay that was something
that
district council have had us include in
our business plan and a strategic
plan for the last 10 years and sometimes
like one time we helped them with their
community connector in covenant
and it was really successful but every
other year we've really struggled to
know how we can support the rural
towns of hiranui when hironoui tourism
get funded a lot more money and they
actually should be helping
wipra with their promotion cheviot
culverden and the likes so we
give a bit of a pushback on that okay so
just as a feedback
yes though apart from the observatory i
feel like oxford is missing out of the
promotion
but yes okay that oxford cast hinterland
was really important
for tourism so i think that could be an
area a bit more focus
potentially um the second thank you
the second question was with the new
strategy talking about
residents promoting the district of
residence promoting to residents yes
have you thought about bringing together
the residence groups to cross-populate
some of that information
no okay just a thought um
as we know most of our visitors are
actually friends and family coming out
from
christchurch and they actually often
convert to being residents
because they just love coming north and
there's so much to do along our beaches
our foothills you know it's exactly in
me
so i spent more of my time out here on
the weekends that i ever did
in christchurch around so um it is about
that local ambassadors telling others to
come out and
yes yeah absolutely excellent well thank
you for that
we've had quite extensive presentation
and
questions so i'll we have a series of
recommendations here
that we received the report and
acknowledged the work carried out by enc
over the years now as for the miz
happy to move and councillor barnett
seconded
mr man just to
particularly thank heather and the team
for the work that they're doing it has
been a
particularly difficult year but i think
it's very clearly contained in the
report the level of activity that's
going on
to support our um with our community
ultimately and our businesses within
that new we heard earlier
from total span uh with their testimony
i guess
of of evidence really of of the
value that they see that enterprise
north canterbury brings to them
and that's actually quite a common theme
i hear
around the place uh from businesses that
are interacting
of that particular value and i i just
like to commend heather and the team for
the work that they've done so stepping
up
through that covert period in particular
provid
achieving some funding support to
give businesses that essential advice
around their financials which actually
is
was really important we had the economic
recovery
advisory group meeting last monday and
i know hither was there but i was really
encouraged
that uh meeting just the snapshot of
those particular
businesses that were represented there
in sector
representatives the natural fact our
local economy
is fearing very well now
tourism is perhaps our um tourism is
doing
better than was expected probably around
but certainly not the international if
you're in the travel
related industry it's certainly more um
difficult and we're aware of that but uh
and i'm hearing from the likes of
campground operators in the round that
they're absolutely chocolate
um coming up in fact if you a friend of
mine who's looking to get a site
um and this is going to go as far away
as pickton to get a location not that
there's anything wrong with going to
pickton but
there was just a lack of local choice
so that's really good in that regard
that we're um picking up but i was
really impressed with
just the general reflection about where
things are going here locally
businesses are picking up really well
um reporting um strong
uh areas around retail but in particular
in kaiapoi i was encouraged too that
a number of the um andrew blackwell was
here a number of the stores
that have been vacant are actually
starting to get tenants in them which is
really good because that was worrying
personally worrying me
the number of cowboy had shifted
effectively into the newer area which is
natural that's to be expected but
leaving
that period that uh area in williams
street where our service center down to
the corner to we've been
corner uh vacant so with a number of um
vacancies so that's encouraging so all
in all either
um i look we've got a
we don't know where our economy is
likely to be um
and then in the near near period but
um with the signals are if we've
survived through march we'll see where
things are at at that point and that's
when we're going to next bring
our economic recovery group together to
see where things are at but
it's encouraging signals as we go into
christmas and not heather thank you to
you and your team for all that you're
doing
i'm um encouraged with your idea also
around a workshop with those who have
some ideas about where they think
marketing and
um and have shown some interest from our
boards
i think that's a really good thing and
we should always be open to new ideas
and new ways that things can be uh be
looked at but uh
to you and the team thanks for all
you're doing and
i think you'll have earned a good break
at christmas looking at your activity
through here so thank you for
uh thank you for that and i have no
hesitation in supporting the report
thank you council obama yes it's an
absolutely fantastic report and a
tribute
to the work of the staff and the board
supporting them and everyone out in the
field who's
kept the ship rowing forward absolutely
astonishing how
well we've managed to do over this time
as a district
even our unemployment stats have
actually started to drop away but which
is actually
really really important to see um as you
know me i'm an exception reporter so i
pick out the little bits i'd like to see
tweaked so that's no reflection on the
report as a whole
and it's always looking towards
improvement which i'm hoping you're
happy with that
um i'm excited by the new visitor
strategy i actually think it is a change
i think it's quite
actually really recognizing our friends
and family market which are always easy
to ignore because they're not
necessarily the big spenders
but they do bring a lot of revenue into
the district and you know as we've
talked about auckland being our new
australia we're going to have to change
the way we market things and the way we
do things to catch that market and stop
them going to queenstown
into victims and places like that um so
i'm really
excited about that i do think and i urge
the board to have a
really close look at our eyesight
strategy um it has become a business
center
it's only open it's not open on the
weekends it's reflective of the change
of what's been going on
so there may be have to be it's 190 000
it's quite a big chunk of the
the business so we really do urge the
board to have a really good look at that
going forward because
that's changing countrywide and we have
to move with that change as well
but we heard from the businesses came to
speak which was excellent the power of
word of mouth
there's a whole lot of free marketing
out there and we've got a lot of people
who
do a lot online we've got a lot of
wonderful
attractions like the food forest who do
lots of marketing online we can tap into
that and the word
we can get the word out there but please
don't forget about the rural area
um i know our townships are really
critically important
but there's so much value in our
countryside a lot of people in
christchurch simply come out for a day
in the country
and i'm so just that's a that's my only
parting thought
we'll call it day in the country then
councillor redmond
thank you madam chair um i would just
like to um
thank enc for all the work you have been
doing
um i'd describe it as awesome really
when you look at those
statistics and you're volunteers and
you've got an amazing team
and next year you'll probably have some
challenges
but with chris christmas coming maybe
you could all
buy your respective other person a big
shed for christmas
so now listen think thank my respective
person
you can never get them big enough right
listen i i think you're doing a
wonderful job and i'm very proud to be
associated with you so well done
everyone thank you councillor ward
well i guess it goes without saying that
some are very proud of what you've been
doing what you've achieved
in particular what you are able to
achieve in gaining
additional funding which we can't
through the council
to really grow and and
be more effective by your negotiating
skills
to get lots of extra funding so i'm well
done
and look forward to working with you
again this year
thank you any other comments no so i'll
put those
oh write a reply yes certainly mr smear
go for it
i just was remiss and not acknowledging
the board
um and it's probably because of a member
of it really but
um but i should have i should have
really acknowledged both
holly as cheering clear holly i think
you're doing a really good job as chair
of the board
i think you've stepped up really well
and certainly appreciate your leadership
um it goes without saying clear clear
it's got uh has got a wide knowledge of
our district
and um we're really lucky to have uh
claire there
and actually a wide range a board with
wide-ranging experience and we have very
good conversation and discussions so
um as well as the staff it's also the
board that are eating
uh real value there so just my thanks to
you for
what you're doing indeed
um thank you all and thank you enc so
i'll it's been moved and seconded so
i'll put those
recommendations all those in favor
please say i
against declare it carried so thank you
very much
for the presentation
and we move on to item 5.2
which is audit new zealand management
report for the year
ending june the 30th and welcome derek
olson to take us
through it
um just before derek
presents his report just on behalf of
the council derek
thank you very much for new zealand and
your team for
prioritizing your audit extremely
difficult year for audits with uh covert
and reflecting those fairly through the
accounts must be
some challenging times for you
just the report from myself
there were three things identified for
the audit this year
in section 4.5 all three of those things
have been attended to so basically
putting the cco's information on our
website
you'll find that that's up there now the
carryovers of the long term plan that's
one issue that we've always grappled
with in terms of our capital works
we presented to the council a
theoretical paper which
identified that we'll never be able to
do 100
of our works because a lot of it doesn't
um
it's not totally in our control but the
uh we're attempting to actually uh
better that
and we're looking at uh better than 85
which
in all papers is an a pass so we'll go
for that one in this period
but that's acknowledged by audit new
zealand
and the last one there was in relation
to
operational expenditure you'll see that
audit new zealand also has the
eyes on the small dollars as well and
i've commented on some ear fears and
accommodation so
just to comment on a few issues there
the council has the eas that oversee
that
function now and they challenge all the
accommodation that goes through that
account they'll also have a pretty good
idea on what accommodation is because
it's all centralized now
the other thing that we use for our
expenditure when we go
domestically is we use a all government
travel agency and they'll also get the
good rates for us but that particular
one i think it might have even been
probably not for noting but i think jim
might have put his hands up for that one
and there were some circumstances
why that occurred just just to
clarify there was one one charge for 320
and it was a i think it was a night in
wellington which
uh in wellington was booked out and that
was the only accommodation i could get
which i needed to be there for so um
yeah i didn't enjoy that either so
we'll let you pass on that one yes
did you want to add something to the
conversation
thank you chair thank you committee
members nothing jeff did an awesome job
in presenting my report so
thank you jeff um just from my
perspective uh
thanks to management for all the
assistance during the audit
um as jeff said i think um waimak was
one of the first audits
so in terms of all the covert issues
that we had to work through from a
council perspective
um there was quite a few issues that we
had to grapple with
as an organization we developed a
questionnaire that council
completed and that has assisted us
greatly in determining whether there are
certain
line items or areas within the financial
statements that have been impacted by
covert and to what extent those have
been fairly reflected
within the financial statements and
within the performance information
i think jeff has already touched on the
three new recommendations
or four new recommendations that we've
made within the report
again just looking at the number of
recommendations the fact that there are
so few i think is a good
indication that management is doing a
great job in terms of internal control
and ensuring there's a good control
environment
um so we are really nitpicking in terms
of the issues that we are picking up you
know the small as jeff said that the
small issues
um but sometimes the oig also has a as
an eye on those on those small issues
you know because um it's all about the
culture that that's created with you
know
within an organization and sometimes if
those small issues are accepted
it creates an environment that that
larger things then then creep in
a big thing of our audit this year as
well was just again the focus
on the valuations of your infrastructure
your infrastructure assets is the
biggest item on your
financial statements so it's just for us
to ensure
that that is correctly reflected and
fairly reflected
so we again went through a process
whereby we looked at the
valuations performed by the independent
valuers
and we were satisfied that that
valuations were appropriately
done and with within the
prescripts of of the law and the various
standards
that's applicable to valuations and
again there was a
net increase of of 40 odd million within
the infrastructure assets
because this year i think you revalued
your three waters and your roading
assets
although the one went down the other one
went up and that's all as a result of
the
specific unit prices driving those
driving those
valuations other than that
i think uh there isn't much to comment
um from that perspective again just to
thank management for
for their assistance during the audit uh
the financial statements that was
present was of a good quality
and as indicated in the report maybe
just a little bit more scrutiny around
the performance information
and the quality assurance process around
that i think going forward can can
assist
us as well thank you chair thank you
questions councillors um
just one to jeff um thank you for your
ordered opinion
um jeff i i raise it with uh
jenny the other day just out of interest
around accommodation and bookings given
that we've
have a difficult well our local travel
industry has faced a lot of difficulty i
know we're in an all
government system but whether it might
be worth
um talking with local agencies for
proposals
at some particular point like house of
travel and well hello world are still
kind of operating reason being is it
just would
maybe be a way of supporting our local
travel industry and wondering if you
could
perhaps consider that thank you
um yes we we could consider it
uh it does provide that bit of tension
on lowest price versus
local supplier and so we could
[Music]
do an exercise on that which
we could bring take to our procurement
group which oversees our procurement and
see whether there's any benefits in that
thank you
any other questions counselors of
anybody
no all right um the recommendations
are there on page
i'm happy uh to move um in this
instance and a seconder i'll speak at
once council award
thank you i'd just like to say that
it's always good to see a report with
so few things to be addressed and i
think that
our team here is well known
for the quality of its work and i
congratulate
them for that uh and yes
congratulations again uh council award
thank you i'd just like to a big thank
you to all the staff
and management for preparing very
thorough reports and
thank you to the audit um division
for put it giving us preference i'm sure
it's quite a relief to come to one of
one of the top councils anyhow so
um thank you for giving us your
consideration and getting us
done so we can move on thank you
any other comments no um i'll put those
recommendations
all in favor please say aye against
a declarat carriage thank you and thank
you very much
all right now we move on to item 5.3
which is the outcomes of our health and
safety
risk register review to september
2020 and we have katrina
i think this is a fit no no
yes i was going to thank you introduce
you
thank you kiara thank you madam chair
councillors um it was a pleasure to be
back again to present
in front of you before going into the
report today i just wanted to spend a
couple of
minutes just introducing you to our new
health safety and quality manager this
is tami makai
and she's just going to spend a couple
of minutes just introducing herself and
giving you a bit of background
for your interest over to you tammy
thank you over to you tell me and
welcome
thank you i don't know what i was more
scared about a bunch of new faces or the
microphone to be fair but um
it will only be a couple of minutes
because i thought i was coming to
watch and learn and then liz whispers to
me i'm going to get you to introduce
yourself so
it will be very brief um look my
background
is 20-plus years in health safety um and
well-being
um and it's a pleasure to be here in my
eighth week yes my eighth week
um i won't go over the whole 20 years
because we'll be here for a little bit
but
uh the large of the last two
organizations i've worked for
um have been the golf group so i worked
there for six years
and learnt a lot about empowering the
people to make the right choices
based on the environment they are in
versus a piece of paper because that
won't keep you safe
um so that was really a good experience
for me
and then the last nine years at meridian
energy so completely different
organizations but very high risk so
come from a background of that as well
so
uh yeah i really
are about engaging people and bringing
the culture into the
organization um versus the policy and
process is very important obviously
um but actually just empowering the
people so
also yeah there's a little there's a
little ad there which tammy hasn't
i think it's um tammy's grandmother was
joyce mciver who was a counselor here
for many years so
he's got a strong connection with our
community
thank you they would have found that
eventually yeah
all right thank you so uh to present the
report today i'm going to take the
report as read i just wanted to
highlight a few things um
in terms of an observation so you will
notice that there have been some changes
to the risk ratings
in relation to the last review that
we've had
the key areas to the changes for the
risk ratings have been
due to the likelihood not due to the
consequence the consequence is still
severe
however um the organization the
management team have spent quite a
considerable time
looking at the effectiveness of our our
control measures and we feel that it is
much more representative
of the impact and the effort that is
being put in to
mitigate and manage those risks
the other thing that i wanted to draw
your attention to as you will notice in
your risk register there is a number of
risks that have
an overdue comment next to them
so there are two reasons for this one is
we're currently going through an
education process with most of our
organization about the transition of the
risk register
from what we used to have to these new
heat maps
and the management of a much more
proactive
assessment profile so the overdue
relates to the review criteria that is
put against those risks and those
mitigation measures
so we expect our managers to actually
review on a regular basis which they set
themselves
what those mitigation factors are just
to make sure that they are still
relevant
and appropriate for those particular
risks
the other reason why the overdue is
there is because we're currently going
through the transition of the new
health safety and quality manager so
transitioning a number of those things
out from charlotte over across to tammy
i just also wanted to mention that it
has been a difficult period in the last
couple of months we
as a health safety and quality team
probably haven't delivered
everything that we have wanted to
deliver when it comes to the risk
register
as you can imagine having a vacancy for
such a significant role has had an
impact on our small team
and that's why we're really excited to
have tammy on board now
and she's pretty much up to speed in
terms of the complexity of what the
organization is about i'm looking
forward to seeing what she
will be able to help me to deliver in
the in the coming years so
open to any questions that you may have
thank you
questions counselors
no all right i think oh councillor duty
yeah thank you um just one thing that i
just
bear aware of which is which is a little
bit overdue
is the well-being strategy for our for
our um
workers it's to me i think that's one of
the
probably one of the very vital things to
make sure their health and well-being is
addressed so
it's just something to think i know that
you'll be working on that
i think yeah absolutely um spot on their
council of duty i think from two
perspectives one the impact from covet
and you'll have the covert risk register
for your information there
but also you know the compounding
impacts of well-being from a from a
difficult year and what that does
uh both within the workplace but also
for people in our community so
it is something that is a priority for
us and we'll be looking at updating that
strategy very soon
thank you you're right
yeah we've got a lot of change yeah
thank you thank you good observation any
other questions
no so um the mayor will
will move the recommendations and who
will second it
council award will second it um mr mayor
uh good reporters always thank you it's
always good to
to know where we're standing and it's a
really important
uh report for us to to be very mindful
of
uh and particularly where things are at
within the organizations
um welcome teaming congratulations on
your role
look forward to working with you i i
knew your mother very well
she was a lovely woman and and was it
ben i think yeah and you've been
very well too so um nice uh
a really nice couple and so your
reputation proceeds you through
through your um your parents who and
your mother in particular who made a
huge contribution to our district so
it's great to have you on board and we
look forward to working with you
guys i'll just reiterate it welcome
tammy
yes i had have had quite a lot to do
with joyce over the years
going back a long long time wonderful
ladies so
welcome thank you very much any other
comments counselors
no well i um pass on my welcome to you
as well and i also um had the pleasure
of
engaging with joyce a lot of the time
over the years so
i'm a marvellous woman so
without any more comments i'll put
those some recommendations a to d
all those in favor please say uh against
declare it
yes yes that's the diseased one yes we
want that moved
thank you all right thank you very much
and we move on to item 5.4
and welcome our corporate planner helene
street
to take us through the non-fine
performance measures over to you hilly
good morning cheering council um i'll
take the reporters
read i do have a couple of questions
from councillor barnett and hopefully
i've got the answers for those um the
report is down on this
similar quarter the same quarter last
year some
of the results are due to covert not all
um
so yeah we are five percent down on last
year
a couple of the questions that counselor
barnett had around some of the
measures that weren't achieved um
[Music]
matt's talking the one with the first
one was the
resource consents 98
target of a hundred percent have you
read
maps yeah are we you happy with the
response to that
yeah um so mata's saying that
looks at the internal system there was
an issue there would seem
that we have actually met the resource
consent time frame requirements for all
consents but have not recorded some
extensions
um electronically there does seem to be
some recording issues there
which is the same response i've had in
regard to
the noise complaints from environmental
health
there does seem to be some issues with
in tech one
in terms of closing off
responding how we respond to complaints
and there is a
new piece of software that i understand
is live now should be ready for the next
quarter
so although we are responding to some
some complaints are not being closed
often
in tech one so therefore when they pull
the results off
it doesn't look as if we have achieved
some of the targets so hopefully that
will be rectified for
next quarter um you
questioned a couple of the water ones
six percent and four cents of the herbal
herbal urban drainage request not
responded to within five days
kelly is saying
that three of the 54 not responded to
within five working days
and they're related to one service
request that was initially assigned
incorrectly assigned to another team
went to roading rather than sewer
one service request was not actioned by
a roading contractor
and one was not actioned by a
subdivision team
so they are having a
bit of an internal review about why
these aren't responded to
in their required time
okay any other questions counselors
helene this has been um three different
business units resource consents
water drainage and esu and i just
wondering is do you think there might be
a need for some education in those areas
about what what relates to your area as
opposed to what relates to their area
and how they're two mesh together
or do you think they need further i.t
support
i think i think you're right on both
points there the esu
and the resource consensus through
tech one the um
you and our team have their own system
for recording
um responses to their service request so
there's two i'm not aware of their
system at all
but um yeah there certainly does i think
because some of these
are coming up quarter after quarter
especially with the drains one so
yeah i think it is it is a good time to
yeah to get them to review their systems
and
and get them to understand that yeah
i think uh we are
in terms of system related issues and
utilities and roading for three waters
um
we're just due to go live with our asset
management information system
which a large part of that is tying
you know front-end service requests to
contractor action
and implementation and monitoring so i'm
anticipating that that
should assist in dealing with it it
still requires individuals
to do the right thing when they get a
request in front of them though which
um that is a point of focus that
our utilities and roading team do focus
on and
actually you know uh the
the tv screen that sits in uh in there
or two teams there is very much
um uh in their face in terms of
responding to
outstanding requests and i think
generally do do a really good job in
that space
thank you subsequent to that jeff do you
think
you look after the it section is it
correct
do you think you could just check out
the issues with tech 1
for both esu and the resource consent
side because obviously resource consent
is a statutory requirement we have to do
there in my understandings we hadn't
failed but the report makes it look like
we have so
it could ask you to check with the i.t
connection issues but with tech one and
those two units
thank you any further questions
councillors
moves i'll second
and that is the recommendation to
receive and notes the measures being
reviewed
uh all those in favor sorry yes thank
you
just very quickly it always seems a bit
hard asking questions of helene because
they actually come from other areas
um and so that's why i just delved a
little deeper and sought the actual
responses from those teams because for
example i knew that
resource consents i knew we were 100 and
so for the report to say that we weren't
was a little strange
i um i understand technical challenges
tech systems don't always talk to each
other
but this this report's actually it's
it's have we done
the right thing so it's a really
important report and so i think it's
really critical that we get some of
those tech issues straightened out if we
can
or we have a commentary in there because
what was lacking was a commentary as to
why it was under the standard however um
that was not the case for drainage and
i would very much like um
drainage and roading to have a look as
to why
um they did not even give a response
within five working days like we will
look at it or it's in the list or we
will
respond kelly has made that really clear
that
um this is actually the contractors
who have not been given a task but then
have not done anything
or contacted or just we have responded
to your request
sent that sort of message within five
days and that's a simple thing
i'm hoping with the it improvement on
service requests that that will become
an automatic process so the contractors
don't have to worry about it
that we have received your request and
we're working on it and then that will
solve that issue
however um we had
one request went round in circles one
request was not ancient
just simply not action so we have not
we in rural drainage service requests we
haven't met the standard
and i would like to see some improvement
thank you councillor and i can only
endorse your comments
um particularly um as
this is our customer facing part of the
organization
and we pride ourselves in being very
responsive um
to that and we have been down here
so i think in the next quarter um not
only the software improvements but also
the response within the organisation and
with our contractors needs focus
but apart from that um thank you for
that report
any other comments counselors no
and now i will put it all those in favor
please say aye against declare
carrot thank you
now we move on to item 5.5 which is our
capital works program quarterly update
for september and welcome chris and don
to take us through it
thank you madam chair this is the first
report for
this current financial year
as you will see it is a reasonably
positive
report in terms of performance to date i
think we're all aware of the danger of
being too optimistic too early in the
year
and that was certainly in mind for both
the asset managers
and then the department managers as well
as myself
in reviewing uh each of the
statuses of the project that were put
forward to us by
uh the project managers however we do
feel we've presented a pretty realistic
picture here we
feel uh in those areas where we have
traditionally struggled
this year there is a different feel
about it we are well advanced with a
number of the more significant projects
and many of them have been discussed
around this and other tables
over the last few months as we have
worked our way through some pretty curly
issues
and and largely in most instances come
out the other side
and are now preparing or
or have started the physical works so
we're in a lot better position i think
than we have been in other years at this
similar time of the year um and in
addition to that
there is also remaining quite a strong
focus on the business as usual smaller
stuff
um both ryan from green space
and kieran from roading are very focused
on the
you know 20 30 40 50 other smaller
projects that
can easily slip off the radar as well
so generally speaking i think this is a
pretty positive but realistic report
we're not feeling it's over optimistic
you will note that there are
some noted as at risk not many noted yet
as delayed
uh the exception to that at the moment
one of the bigger exceptions to that you
will notice that the piracy street
cycleway
has been signaled as delayed we're still
hoping for that not to be the case we
have got a process underway and there'll
be a report going
to uh the community board in december
which we're hoping will move that
forward one way or the other and allow
us to spend
that money but we at this stage due to
the complexity of that one are signaling
it is delayed
um but other than that uh chris unless
you've got further
to add we're happy to take questions
questions counselors
go through redmond ah thank you madam
chair
um don you refer to the parakeet street
cycle way
um i see there is a plan of how that
will be addressed at the council and
possibly utilities and roading
which i wouldn't be happy about since
i'm not on that committee
um one of the options you indicated was
that it could be held over until
february
now what impact would that have on your
program of works or getting the work in
bracket street
or alternatively reallocating those
funds elsewhere
is february too late or will that mark
up all these
uh statistics here uh it won't make it
up because the statistics are signaling
it as delayed
so this this the statistic the report in
front of you assumes
we will not get that money fully spent
we're still
very much targeting trying to get it
spent if in fact we cannot get a
final decision one way or the other
before christmas i think that almost
certainly would be the death knell of
getting all of the money spent this year
um and so there will be a report coming
to the council to consider that matter
as to who who should consider it uh and
i won't
talk at this stage about that but i
still do hope i am still hopeful for a
final decision for christmas
but this is assuming that doesn't happen
any other questions counselors
all right i've got a um
three recommendations there to receive
and note the addition of the stimulus
and shovel ready
and the achievement across
the capital expenditure councillor ward
will
move and the mayor will second council
award
thank you i just want to congratulate
you
all for um really hard work that you've
had to do
and and fast footing to get to the
shovel ready project and stimulus
projects planned
and ready to go and underway and i see
there's a lot of
things happening around the town with
the general roading and
also i'd like to also congratulate on
the stadium
project which is going faultlessly
so all in all we're in great hands and i
know you've all been flat out
and i i really appreciate we all really
appreciate
the great work that you're doing for us
and and i've got great confidence that
everything's going to be achieved on
time
thank you mr me
i like council awards optimism um and
appreciate that but i'd just like to
endorse the comments
around the the program the area there's
a very ambitious program
and this council is ambitious for its
community but
we've got to be realistic at times too
and the pressure that that does place on
our system but
i know and um other reports we've got
coming to us today
to talk about our roading program and
where we're at and other projects and
um it's noting also the stimulus and
shovel really has put a lot of pressure
on us to deliver
also but if i'm
comfortable with where things are at i
said at the time and we were doing the
shovel ready and stimulus i think we
need to be realistic of the pressure
that we place on our staff
around delivery um we've got an
ambitious program
that means that there will be some
juggling around timing so
and that's our responsibility too when
we're setting that
so um we often there's often comments
about the capital project well we need
to take some ownership on that too
and you know our community have
expectations we all do
but i also want to say thanks to our
staff
for to all our staff for the work that
you're doing managing that program
to keep up with the growth and also the
program that we had
that we had available to us um through
the crown
so thanks don thanks chris and team that
are in the background supporting us
thank you
any other comments counselors
no all right um we'll put that
recommendation
oh oh well did you want to write a reply
no okay um i'll put that recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
against uh declare it carried thank you
very much
okay now we move on to item 5.6 which is
the
sefton community library application for
rates remission
and invite marie to the table to tell us
all about this
thank you madam chair three years ago
i came to the audit and risk committee
for a one-off grant
for the sifton community library
and now i'm asking for the third grand
the the road to getting this
property sold has been
a lot longer and more complicated i
think than anybody
thought it was going to be and um
we are further along in the process but
there's
still a way to go so to date
the trustees have changed there was a
big hurdle because
the trustees hadn't changed for many
years
and that had to go to the court to get
that
that sorted and so now we've done that
and now there's another
another job to be done and that is
winding up the trust
so the committee and the
solicitor are gathering information
together
and the council's green space team are
helping them with that
and it's all about yeah is the facility
required for community use as a library
um and they need to um
they need to convince the courts that
um winding up the trust and
disposing of the property is the best
option so that's where they're at now
i have a feeling they're getting the
legal services for free
so it's not a priority and that's
partly one of the reasons why it's being
drawn out but
this this committee of volunteers are
where they're at and
a further rates remission would really
help them
along the way and i did ask the
solicitor
is this the last time and explained that
you know this
is policy is intended to be one-off
assistance and
the answer i got was that yes by this
time next year we should be
sorted excellent thank you
any questions counselors
uh councillor barnett moves
i'm here with a second or no council
award
um councillor barnard
that's lord i'm saying
all right any other physical counselor
redmond
thank you madam chair and thank you
marie i've
been involved on the periphery with the
shefton library
and i drove past there at the weekend
and it's actually a worse condition
than i last remembered i am hopeful
green space and paula from the library
have been assisting
helmore stewart with an affidavit to go
with the
next application and that's been worked
on
this week and some amendments made it's
more than 10 years ago
since the library closed
it is a lengthy and a complicated
process because
the last trustees i think were about 100
years out of date
so getting that first hurdle dealt with
and the current committee
on the title was an achievement it's
just a matter of now persuading
the courts that there is no need for a
library
of this nature and sefton and
the last suggestion we had during the
week was we'll send them a photo of the
library
externally and internally and they'll
certainly get the idea that it's not fit
for purpose
so um i i would hope this is the last
time
that this request will come here but i'm
certainly supportive i think it's a
a worthy case um to support
and hopefully the last time you'll be
coming here with it marie
thank you any further comments okay
um it's been moved and seconded i'll put
it all those in favor please say
aye against declare it carrot
thank you marie thank you now we now
move on to
item 5.7 which is our sustainability
strategy implementation our first
quarter
final quarter report and invite mike
o'connell
to talk us through it thank you
over to you
good morning this is the this is the
final uh
report in the series of of four of the
um implementation of
said strategy the strategy that we put
out uh
adopted a year ago uh the corporation
sustainability strategy and action plan
um
and just wanted to say a couple of
things about it
um this is the sort of the stage two is
already underway
um and i note that we a lot of the work
that has been done in this
period has been done through the the
sustainability strategy coordination
group which
is also the sustainability champions
but now that stage two will be much we
um
work much better with an elected member
working group that has been
set up back in uh in july um
apologies that seems to be somehow
the wrong attachment seems to have been
put at the back i don't know how that
happened but um
it's some of the information there may
be a little seem a little bit dated but
i'm happy to explain any of those things
that seem
unclear from what's reported in there
um it's just it's been it's been a year
of
of uh some highlights i could say um
we've we've
pretty well got a three bin system
internal bin system to be rolled out
and it's been it's timed and nicely with
the refurbishment and the the eqc work
that's been done in the service center
running your service center we've also
had some good wins around
out getting rid of electronic waste and
also getting containers for catering
just so that we stop disposing of
[Music]
material that otherwise end up in
landfill we can keep the stuff in the
system
and also we've also had it's not
directly me but we've had
success around um uh the electric
vehicle charging stations
and ongoing work around um our vehicle
fleet
um so look i'll just
leave it there just to say that this is
early steps we're finding our way still
as an organization as as as a
working group but this is now leading
into better uh
to a um something we think that was
going to work out much
much more smoothly with this working
group the the the elected members
working group nikki is not a part of
this
group issue to run to help work with
with the sustainability champions
through the next stage two of this
of the organizational strategy so look
i'll just
leave it at that ticket that's been read
and just happened to take any
questions any questions
against thanks mike and
note in there it says that the obviously
the solar panels for the water
um plant were delayed probably due to
covert expense i imagine
do you know when that's going to be
re-looked at
if you have any idea is this this is the
water panels for the solar array or for
the
for the where is it
so the sewer treatment plant sorry i
believe that report that that project
has been
put on hold uh
mr palmer yeah i think the key issue
uh that we're looking at is back at the
economics
it's back to the economics question
again which
uh relates um
i think the conversation uh relates to
the future of t y point and what that
might do to
the spot power price for new south
island
and new zealand and if that would come
to
pass then that may
its closure would make
this option in the nearer term
potentially less viable
um than otherwise would be because
that's likely
to either if that the surplus energy we
put back into the grid is likely to go
back and be sold at a very low price
and therefore makes the economics
questionable and i think
the team are doing some further
evaluation to understand
uh the economics of that and
when the timing of that would be better
suited if that did come to pass so
we are waiting a little bit to see what
the what the government's view is
on supporting the smelter
because that will have an impact so my
question would be
why is this in a sustainability report
as opposed to just in a normal
operational report
if we're not looking at it as a
sustainability project only as an
economic one well we are looking at as a
sustainability project it is one of the
sustainability projects but it
but it requires a significant capital
spend to actually
generate uh well uh
significant investment so um the payback
has to has to stack up
and um and that
many of the actions here uh have
financial implications and they need to
be evaluated
um this this report is capturing that
that is an initiative
mike's not responsible for the delivery
of the initiatives he's
he's been very helpful in providing us a
report of
a collective view of what are the
initiatives going on
across our organization
so just subsequent to that just teasing
that point out
are we saying that as a council
where where does the economics versus
the sustainability
knowing that sometimes sustainable
things are actually more expensive
yep and ultimately that will be a matter
for the council to determine and
we want to in that business case
evaluation make sure that that
evaluation is updated to reflect now the
changing circumstances so
that's a matter that should be
determined by the council um
[Music]
ideally you know when it was initially
uh
signaled it had a payback which actually
had two wins both economic and a
sustainability perspective
it's question now whether it has both
ticks both boxes
today and ultimately that will be a
decision for the council to reflect on
um i had no uh
main power of committed to installing
solar at the stadium and that's a
that's a good initiative and uh
hopefully
i think uh they have a slight advantage
in that space and that they are an
energy trader as well as a lions company
and
so they are able to
utilize their broader energy trading
role albeit a very small role
um to a net benefit which we don't have
as we're not an energy trader
thank you uh any further questions
councillors
no right um a mover
councillor williams has been very quiet
so you you'd like to move this wouldn't
you
you would thank you and councillor
barnett would like to second i think
um councillor williams should say
something
yeah that's all self-explanatory um
with the um solar panels that the um
um sewer works um i think there's a cost
because we would have had to
actually have a set amount we'd pay for
our units of power for a long period of
time while we decide and
um it's actually going to be dearer than
what we're actually paying now for a
while but would have eventually um
come into it so there's it's actually
not the cost of the panels it's the um
long-term cost of what we'll be paying
for power which would be um
offset on it which is a big problem
there so
so okay
yes this has been a very difficult time
to try and look at a sustainability
strategy
when we look at trying to actually reuse
and recycle and yet we've been able
we've had to do to covert go back to
high hygiene
practices which means we haven't been
able to reuse cups so much we haven't
been able to
there's been a lot more disposable items
which are reintroducing into our
waste stream um it's going to be a
really difficult
question that we're going to have to ask
as a council going forward
economics versus sustainable choices and
i'm not just talking about this
one example our community is starting to
ask us to show leadership
in this space however they're also
asking us for their rates to be
affordable
so we're going to have to keep
questioning this as we go forward
i really don't want the sustainability
strategy to become just paying lip
service to it
i really do want to see us showing that
leadership
but i appreciate that the balance is
always going to have to be there and
covet certainly hasn't helped
at all because we are going to be
looking at having to be very
careful about reusing items for probably
quite some time so thank you mike for
sticking with us through this difficult
time
i am pleased to see the small measures
that we are making a little bit of
traction with electric vehicles
with some composting in the kitchens and
once we have our kitchens back that will
be easier
and i'm just saying thank you stick at
it and it's really good to see that
group of champions who are very
passionate about this initiative
thank you councillor um mr me
thank you mike for your report it's uh
important that we do keep measuring this
i want to make it clear that i don't pay
lip service to this so i
i i view this as really important to our
council it's why in the
term of this council we recommended
the appointment of a climate change and
sustainability portfolio holder
and council meetings and i want to
acknowledge the work that she's
is doing in this space and keeping
connected with
um basically across our organisation
uh the work that we're doing in this
area i acknowledge council of arnold's
remarks she's absolutely right
that it is a it is a difficult area
particularly in the environment that
we're in but
um there are opportunities for us to
show leadership
in many spaces i've just recently become
the chair of the
um mural forum on climate change uh and
they're
you know in that space the other
councils are also grappling
with this issue and how they are
responding in the new year we'll
hopefully if the
i'd like to bring the portfolio holders
of respect for respective councils where
there are and if there aren't to come
together for a discussion about
how we advance these issues on a more
re category regional area because they
are important and we should be connected
a lot more than we are it's not saying
we're not doing work because there is
work going on
in other councils so it's an area that's
important mike i know i've gone a bit
broader and added climate change in
there but
it's it's all connected so um thank you
for the work that you're doing the staff
being champions i
came across staff member the other day
with um putting putting the
um on the recycling bins out and they
said it just made a real difference
that they actually have those bins now
whereas they've been battling not
battling but
been working to get those implemented so
the steps towards the right
doing the right thing and that's showing
leadership so thanks for
the work that you and the team are doing
internally connected with
um counselor mailings in her work so
thank you
thank you mr may any other comments um
councillor williams
write a reply no okay and
i can just thoroughly endorse the
comments that the mayor has made
and you know the project this may be
slow but
it is um the right thing to do and we
need to
always have that in mind so i'll put
those recommendations
um all those in favor please say aye
against uh declare it carries thank you
mike
and we now move on to item 5.8
which is the financial report for
the quarter ending september the 30th
and
paul christensen will take us through it
thank you paul
this report is for the council's uh
financial performance for the um
period to september 20. um
i think three main points i'd like to uh
cover is
the surplus was 1.2 million against a
budget of 0.8 billion
revenue has is around our own budget
and particularly fees and charges are
slightly over budget 5.4 million versus
4.4
going into this year um that was
probably of concern
uh following the covert lockdown we were
unsure about
where we would be with revenue um so and
i think that's
following what the rest of the country
is seeing and that
the fees and charges is money is still
coming in particularly
around consent revenue
and lastly debt remains at 160 million
and we're expecting not to we won't be
drawing down any more
debt uh before the new calendar year
so that'll stay there before then
there any questions on the report any
questions counselors
um council award i see we were expecting
to go up to 180 million
in debt um so
is because we're still was that provided
for
um with with projects that weren't
completed last year
um um
effectively we do them in
big big lumps really um so we drew down
15 million new debt uh just before
the end of the last financial year which
is then the cash for paying
for capital work going forward so
while at the moment that hasn't been
used as fast as we would have expected
so um uh we'll expect
that that uh particularly with projects
such as the uh stadium
um uh going um
ahead um that will get we should uh need
to
have to draw down another
tranche of debt and that should be um
and further into next year maybe march
april
we do have a renewal
um 25 million of debt to be renewed um
in may um anyway because as um
it fools you so um we may also tie it in
with that depending on how the cash is
going
just to help me so the 25 million that
you say that's falling due next match
just can you explain to me what effect
that that has
is that um is that to be repaid
yeah um so so we take our debt out and
uh bonds with the lgfa and so
those bonds have a a life it could be
uh depending on how how long you're
taking up from uh we usually take them
anything between three and five years
um so uh we're because of the debt we've
now got
um we essentially have a program uh
where the
the debt is timed so that it won't all
fall due in one year um but it's now
to the point where because our debt is
160 million
if 25 million is we're now getting about
a fifth of it falling due each year
which is what we work on
is to try and get it around about that
level so every year we will have
renewals of around 20 somewhere between
20 and 30 million
and so that's a normal process and what
we'll do is just go back to lgfa
and replace the bonds that we have with
with the new lot of bonds
thank you for that any further questions
councillor redmond
uh question for either jeff or paul in
clause 4.9 our current standard poor's
rating is double a with a negative
outlook
um it's up for review in march which
will come around very quickly have there
been any discussions with standard and
poors
and do we have any indication of what
the
outlook whether it will remain the same
we did well i think last time and
i think jeff you were involved with a
lot of that work
is there any sort of um
word on what might happen in march
i just had a little primary discussion
that it might be done
through
the internet or zoom or whatever
so the interviews will be done through
that basis and
probably done offline
so the indication is at this stage and
haven't looked at the profile but we'll
probably add
adding a little bit to the own profile
but not a lot which
means the indication would be
that we'd probably go back to stable uh
not positive
but so the negative it would be double a
uh stable and um
yeah so it should be a good result for
us fingers crossed and
we don't have any uh disasters or
anything like that they come along
yeah i think i think uh the
like you know looking at the health the
draft ltp will be something they will be
clearly focused on and i think where the
council has looked to
uh move for example right you're a
service center project
out uh we'll see you know
not the same level of death that they
might have anticipated from last year so
i'm expecting it should be at least as
stable a position i think the main
caveat around that's
beyond our control which is geopolitical
world and national economy which
uh how that will affect all
businesses councils and governments not
just us
so i think that'll probably be one of
the things that
will be the overarching issue that
they'll focus on
thank you any other
questions no all right
we've got a recommendation there that we
receive the report
and note that the council surplus is in
line with the year-to-date budget
um council williams will say uh will
move it
and yes and councillor
council awards seconds council williams
yeah that's looking good and long's been
keep those eyes up there
that will be good
just a very well managed budget and
thanks to everybody
um hard work so um we'll just keep a
close eye on it and see how
the next few months pan out
oh councillor burnett
yes i'm just trying to think of a time
when i've seen all of the front section
without a cross beside it so i was very
very pleased to see this
report that everything has been kept
well within budget you've done a great
job and very trying times so thank you
very much
indeed i'll endorse that
well done so far fingers crossed
and let me just to add my comments to
that and support
what colleagues have said this is one of
the real strengths of our councils
around our financial performance
so thank you to paul jeff
in particular and the team uh something
that we
uh you know when we when i talk to other
councils they
often talk about where we're at and how
we manage things so
it's a real benchmark but i don't mean
to sound complacent
it's to be complacent because we're not
but it's an area that's particularly
well managed and
councillor redmond was right to ask
around our standard and pause because
it's certainly
something that we've worked very hard to
maintain so we want to see it maintained
too because it
makes a real difference and how our
community judges our performance and how
we borrow
and what rates we borrow at so thank you
team
really good result very pertinent
comments from the mayor
so any more any more comments no um
i'll put those recommendations that we
receive and note
the surplus in line with the
year-to-date budget all those in favor
please say aye
against declare it carried thank you
very much paul
all right now we move on to item six
which is our portfolio
updates and i invite councillor ward to
talk to us
about audit risk ltp and excellence
program
thank you well um excellence program of
course
i guess our standard and pause rating
says it all doesn't it um so we we
haven't had
um too much discussion on that ltp
there's been a lot of work
um going on there um we've had lots of
meetings
on the long-term plan and of course it's
very difficult
um to um to plan so far ahead but
it's sort of we've we're just saying
let's just steady as she goes and do
what we would normally do
and so that's the philosophy that's been
taken
um i've had lots of meetings with town
centre strategies workshops
dpnr meetings and workshops civic press
civic precinct refurbishment is going
along
quite well really well um some
nice nice carpet tiles have been chosen
which hopefully you will appreciate
kai for mixed business workshops that's
still in progress
town centre activation workshops
in progress ring your airfield advisory
group
is yeah long term there's a few things
happening there
um i just would like to note there that
the atc
are having a flying weekend at the
airfield on the 28th and 29th of
november
be lots of activity up there with young
ones learning to fly during doing
orienteering lots of things if anybody
wants to go and have a look and also
have a look at our
1.2 kilometer trees that we planted just
recently
see the growth there that would be good
but i've also spoke to enc to see if we
can
have some photography done there so that
we can put it into our
promotions uh for our macro area of the
activities that we're doing
so we'll try and we've been waiting to
have that since
prior to covert so that's getting
underway for the end of november and
also
attended the civil defense workshop so
um
as far as that the long-term plan and
excellence and everything that's me for
now thank you
council lord
coming up there is a meeting with um
adam
feely from uh lg ep excellence program
looking for
feedback on the last exercise that we
went through so
there's it's a meeting that the um ce
and myself have been invited to
uh to attend when he's here with um
simon martin so
just to uh provide that there's an
update do i get involved
um any any questions of council award
on her update no yes councillor
cool uh councillor barnett invite
council labona to talk
about the communications and customer
service portfolios
right starting with customer services
this time
um e-services are moving along they're
working on paperless direct debits
and they've had some issues with account
to account
transactions with the major banks but
that's now being resolved
and so they're working very very hard
wanting to get rates payments online so
that's going to be really really
useful for people when they want to do
that online and
they're also looking at the service
request responsiveness forms having a
demo today
on service requests so the online
responsiveness of service request will
get some information coming later on
once that's been tested communications
has had a busy 12 months i'll send you
out the full communications plan that
aleister sent me
but if we just quick summary 13
communication plan
49 news stories 90 media inquiries and
nine public consultations
um and that's i don't know if that's
including or not including covered but
certainly covered on top was a very busy
time the most popular items in let's
talk
were the natural hazards in the news
with skewbridge
issues webmaster continues to be a
full-time role
just doing the website over 150 requests
a month
for both internal and people using
mainly internal the website has over 118
000 visits a year and that's growing
the most popular this year's been dog
registrations
and of course raids uh facebook has
added 194 likes
the top post was the christchurch
northern corridor night walk
it's a huge interest in the motorway and
the top video was stadium waimakariri so
hats off to the people who did that
video
now planning ahead planning for the long
term plan and district plan
consultations which are going to be the
main focus
and i haven't heard about but i hear
there is an appointment in the wings for
the person who's doing the half comms
half dp
roll but i haven't had any information
on that yet and the website refresh
which we've got that little budget of
30k a year is the next thing they'll be
working on
thank you thank you councillor any
questions of council about it
no all right thank you both for that
update
and we moved now to questions of which i
have none
and urgent general business i have none
of that either